in the middle of the channel the remains
of a flimsy dinghy it had set off from
the french shore a few hours earlier
almost everyone who'd been on this boat
died
in these cold waters
as on so so many other days hundreds of
people had left the french beaches
in an array of boats some seaworthy
others manifestly not fit for purpose
but this wasn't a day like any other
instead it was shrouded in death
in the hours that followed the french
interior minister the equivalent of the
home secretary came to the hospital here
in northern france he blamed people
smugglers and said britain and france
must cooperate more
we really have to work together
two major countries who are friends we
have to fight against these traffickers
together
and they play on our borders and sadly
our differences in legislation
sometimes this means there's a slight
lack of cooperation
possibly we are not working together
enough yet but we really must fight
against these criminals just as we fight
against terrorists
inside this hospital is the moor
containing the bodies of the victims who
perished in the freezing waters of the
channel testimony to the dangers
of that crossing a criminal
investigation has been launched and a
number of suspected people smugglers
have been arrested the question is
whether this terrible loss of life will
stimulate a new debate about how to
manage cross-channel migration
britain has long claimed the french
should do more to stop these boats
leaving
last month we filmed these people
running down a beach near calais
with their boat heading for the uk and
watched by the french police who did not
intervene
but now political debate has coincided
with tragedy one of the first people to
reach the scene in the middle of the
channel was lifeboatman charles
it was really dramatic there were
floating bodies it was really very
shocking we recovered all the people we
saw and bought we recovered six people
all dead
there was one woman who said he was
pregnant and a young man in 18 to 20
years old and the rest were men
this area of northern france is dotted
with groups of people
desperate to reach the uk
prepare to pay thousands to smugglers
and also to accept great risks
now those risks have come horribly true
adam parsons sky news calais